in our other videos
we talked about the basics of
fine-tuning a language model with
tensorflow
and as always when i refer to videos
i'll link them below
but still can we do better so here's the
code from our model fine tuning video
and while while it works we could
definitely tweak a couple of things
by far the most important thing is the
learning rate
in this video we'll talk about how to
change it which will make your training
much more consistently successful
in fact there are two things we want to
change about the default learning rate
for adam
the first is that it's way too high for
our models
so by default adam uses a learning rate
of 10 to the minus 3
which is very high for training
transformers we're going to start at
5 by 10 to the minus 5 which is 20 times
lower than the default
and secondly we don't just want a
constant learning rate we can get even
better performance
if we decay the learning rate down to a
tiny value
or even to zero over the course of
training
so that's what this polynomial decay
schedule thing is doing
that name might be intimidating
especially if you only vaguely remember
what a polynomial is for maths class
so i'll show you what that decay looks
like in a second but first we need to
tell the scheduler
how long training is going to be so that
it decays at the right speed
and that's what this code here is doing
so we're computing
how many mini batches the model is going
to see over the entire training run
and to compute that we're taking the
size of the training set
dividing it by the batch size which
gives us the number of batches per epoch
and then we're multiplying that by the
number of epochs to get the total number
of batches
it's going to see over the whole
training run so once we know how many
batches how many training steps we're
taking
we just pass all of that information to
the scheduler and we're ready to go
so what does the polynomial decay
schedule look like
with default options it's actually just
a linear schedule
so it looks like this it starts at our
initial value which is 5 by 10 to the
minus 5 or five e minus five
and then it decays down at a constant
rate until it hits zero right at the
very end of training
so why do they call it polynomial and
not linear
well if you tweak the options you can
get a higher order
a truly polynomial decay schedule but
there's no need to do that right now by
default
you get a linear schedule and if you
were aware that a linear function is a
special case of a polynomial
you can feel proud so that aside how do
we actually use the scheduler
so this is easily we just pass it to
adam you'll notice the first time when
we compiled the model we just passed the
string
atom keras recognizes the names of
common optimizers and loss functions if
you pass them as strings
so it saves time and it avoids imports
to do it that way if you only want the
default settings
but we're professional machine learners
now with our very own learning rate
schedule
so we have to do things properly so the
first thing we do is we import the
optimizer
then we initialize it with our scheduler
in the learning rate argument
and then we compile the model using our
new optimizer
and whatever loss function you want
we'll leave that unchanged this will be
sparse categorical cross-entropy if
you're following along from the
fine-tuning video
but it can be anything else that you're
using yourself
so now we have a high performance model
ready to go
all that remains is to fit the model
just like we did before
and remember because we've compiled the
model with the new optimizer and the new
learning rate
we actually don't need to change
anything about the fit.call at all we
just call fit here
exactly the same command we used before
or if you've
seen in other videos but now we get a
beautiful training with a nice
smooth a good initial learning rate and
a solid learning rate decay
and you will get much better performance
as a result